five o'clock in the afternoon in the
village of moral pay she on South ami
island Francisco de Santos comes back
after a days fishing in South Tommy and
principe some 3,000 people make a living
off the sea Francisco has been fishing
for 30 years it's been another bad day
he only caught three fish and he Lord
meant there was a time when I would go
out and within two hours I'd bring back
enough fish to eat and sell as well as
to buy things for my home but today
sometimes we spend three or four hours
at sea and then come back to the beach
without any fish local NGO Morocco wants
to protect the marine ecosystem while
ensuring artisanal fishings future
marine biologist alesio NATO works for
morata he tells local fishermen why they
should only use authorised Nets this 40
millimeter blue net is selective all the
small fish slip through it and it only
traps the adult fish but these two nets
here people please if you want to
guarantee your future don't use these
nets
fishing nets were the mesh smaller than
35 millimeters were banned in 2014
alicia has to convince people here that
the regulation was brought in to protect
their fish stocks said join up with the
fishermen unable to capture adult fish
they've adopted non-selective meshes
trapping everything including juveniles
and fingerlings if you catch them this
will damage the ecosystem and will
destroy all these species the
fishermen's will then be storing up
trouble for the future well most will
see you boo coolest super song the
village of neves around 30 kilometers
from the capital sauter may Alicia shows
local fish vendors who will be selling
the fish some conservation techniques
the captions to become served as soon as
possible to maintain quality after
cleaning the fish are placed in salt and
vinegar to enhance their flavor Gnawa
elysian NATO has taught best practices
to fishing communities all over the
country
we can smoke the fish today they're
fresh and they won't spoil even without
putting them in the refrigerator we
don't bring them to the market we buy
them on the beach prepare them and
smoked them the fish smoking kiln was
donated by murata it also helped them
found their own vendors Association
there are seven small organizations like
this in the country and some fifteen
percent vendors now smoke their own fish
striking the right balance between
artisanal fishing and conservation will
take time but eligio Neto believes the
best of both worlds is within reach and
that he can help make artisanal fishing
sustainable vamos did we do p we will
have a lot of fish in RC having such a
lot of fish the fishermen will be able
to fish responsibly and still be able to
make money their economy will grow
living conditions and fishing
communities will continue to improve the
vendors will also benefit mismo quiz' as
every morning francisco dos Santos sets
out to sea again he hopes he'll have
more luck today and bring back enough
fish to feed his family and to sell the
market